[Music]
[Applause]
game four Eastern Conference Finals
Celtics in the heat 8 30 Eastern on TNT
the heat favored by one and a half
Reggie Miller will be on the call with
Kevin Harlan coming up tonight reg joins
us on the program we'll get to that
coming up in a moment your take away
from the Lakers in the Nuggets is what
I think people all season long
especially in these postseason playoffs
have underestimated how good Denver was
we wanted to find those other shiny
opposite objects like Phoenix like the
Lakers like Golden State
and the prettiest girl was always
standing right in front of us the whole
time and that's Denver
um I think jokic
proved why he was a back-to-back MVP
um and I think Jamal Murray showed that
his bubble performances uh in Orlando a
couple of years ago weren't a fluke and
hopefully there are young players out
there that are suffering or have had
setbacks like Jamal Murray had with you
know the ACL
tear and shows that you can come back
from
those type of events and still play at a
very high level well coached they're
deeper than most teams
um again we weren't expecting this but
they've been there all along Theodore
well maybe we weren't expecting it I
don't know if people were hoping for it
so it's it's almost like you have to
begrudgingly say Denver's a better team
and and the Joker's the best player in
the game right now at least playing at a
you know this kind of level there but
it's still the Lakers and the Lakers
will always get attention win or lose
and then LeBron gave us that nugget at
the end of the game where he's like I
got to think about this I don't know
about coming back what what is he saying
there Reg
well first of all
I think it's
it's unfortunate because we should be
and I know we started off talking about
Denver
um it takes away from their shine
because that's all the talk in that
series and after game four was uh Lebron
May retire which he is not
he had he was an assist away from a
triple double he has owed 45 next season
and 50 the following year he's not
walking away from that
but here's the talk and
um I get it the greatest player of his
generation but he's not going anywhere
people so relax do they have to make
roster moves obviously it's the Lakers
they always do they made a major one
during uh all-star weekend that got them
to this place in the Conference Finals
but
um he's not going anywhere Theodore in
my opinion I but there's there's
something attached to this Ridge
right I think the emotions of being
swept
and he he came out and said this is the
best team I've faced while in a Laker
uniform yeah okay these are emotions
coming up
it's difficult when you when you are
part of a final four situation you are
one step away and this is a guy in
LeBron James who's been to the finals
what 10 11 times and he's part of the
final four you're one of four teams
getting ready to play for the Ultimate
Prize and they had an unbelievable
comeback in game one but came up short
LED most of the game in game two until
Jamal Murray got hot you had two chances
to capture home court advantage you lose
both of them and then
Denver just put it on them in game three
and you had a chance to win game four
but again up 15 LeBron has 30 in the
first half
but they just didn't have enough those
are emotions surfacing and that's when
you hear I got to think about things and
then now Twitter goes crazy oh my
goodness LeBron is retiring he's not
retiring he's just pondering how about
that he's pondering moving forward he's
not thinking about retirement he's just
pondering his basketball career but if
you're thinking about retiring then
retire that's the same but he's not
going to return okay but that's why I'm
thinking there's more to I understand in
the moment uh we just got swept people
are gonna attach this to my legacy that
Michael never got swept I mean he knows
what's happening here yes he did yes he
did Michael did get swept by Boston
they played a five-game series and they
lost those three games he's never been
swept in the best of seven series but
the great Larry Bird was swept in the
best of seven and against the Bucks I
know but nobody nobody brings those
things up right Matthew Johnson it
happened twice in the best the seven
Series in the NBA Finals yep in the NBA
Finals magic was swept twice so stop
sitting oh my goodness LeBron he got
swept it happens to to the greatest of
great okay do you think LeBron wants
Kyrie to play for the Lakers
well of course I'm sure he does
do you think Kyrie will play for the
Lakers next season I do not because I
think Mark Cuban is going to go to Kyrie
with a huge suitcase
and open it up and he's gonna say where
do I sign I I just think there might
have been an under the table handshake
between Cuban and management
and uh Kyrie's team I I think that is a
smart move for the Mavericks
well they got to try to do something
um to keep Luca happy because Luca could
be walking out the door as well in a
couple of years but they should have
done nothing
before and not traded those players away
it felt like they had complementary
players for Luca they did and and I
thought it made them a a better team
because they knew their roles well
certainly defensively it made them
better case in point oh yeah while they
were in the Conference Finals last
season
Golden State and what they did against
Phoenix and you know dropping them in
game seven on the road
um but Kyrie is one of those players you
can't take your eyes off the problem is
both of them don't play any defense and
those complimentary players can they
find some of those to surround them with
yeah yeah right we're talking to Reggie
Miller Hall of Famer he'll be on the
call tonight 8 30 Eastern on TNT who who
gets the blame in uh Boston
I think there's enough of it to go
around
here I'm going to applaud coach Missoula
he fell on the sword in his post game
presser you saw that I didn't have my
team ready to play but what does that
mean reg exactly and and here's the
thing
when I saw that and I'm looking at that
that is not your job job to get Reggie
Miller ready to play that's my job
I've got to get myself ready to play
players need to start looking themselves
in the mirror I applaud coach for
falling on the sword for taking it
Taking the brunt of it he's 34 years old
he's probably trying to gain some
some friction in that locker room right
trying to get these guys to you know Buy
in I'll take the hit for this but these
dudes need to look at the mirror
Theodore uh Brown Tatum and I love Jason
Tatum these dudes you look at their
numbers as a team they're shooting 29
from three they're uh Jaylen Brown's two
of 20 from three
uh
look in the mirror gentlemen look in the
mirror but I don't know how you
disappear the way Jason Tatum does
sometimes like he's there and he's
unbelievable and then there are times
when you go hey didn't even take a shot
in the fourth quarter like I I don't
understand how
his mind works
but also too I'm going to give credit to
Miami and Miami's defense they are
changing a lot of things they're going
from Zone boxing ones man they're
dropping on them they're going under
they're showing him a lot of coverage
and let's not forget he's 25 24 25 yeah
so as as great as he's been up to this
point fourth in MVP voting he's still a
young player and yes he can give you
numbers but at other times
you know he he goes south but
I believe that the Celtics they'll look
you can't get any worse than it was in
game three right they can't play
anything so I feel they're going to give
Better Effort I just think the heat are
just on another level right now and
after witnessing what Denver did last
night
they kind of want to be on same footing
with them going into the NBA Finals I
think it's a better game tonight Better
Effort by Boston I just think Miami is
just so locked in right now who does
Jimmy Butler remind you of
kind of reminds me of that black cat a
little bit he has that attitude
um no he reminds me of you me yes
because regular season he'll get you 18
19 a game postseason he just kind of
cranks it up a notch has another level
in in terms of that yes
um look I just looked at the season in
the big picture there were certain games
during the regular season maybe 10 or so
that you get up for that are big
um but in whole you just want to be
playing well
build chemistry numbers really didn't
matter for me but postseason give me the
ball and let's go to work
and I always try to build up my fitness
towards the second half of the year and
I think the heat culture is somewhat
like that but Jimmy is like that Jimmy
it's all about performing when the
lights in the stage is the brightest and
the biggest and
these to me
it's his Supporting Cast these dudes
would die they would run through brick
wall for him and that's what I it's love
I love seeing The Supporting Cast Thrive
off of what Jimmy Butler and how he sets
them up and
how they support him it's just an
agreement you see that a little bit with
Denver too you know Brown uh Aaron
Gordon uh kcp the way they play off of
jokish and Murray they understand their
roles we know what we know what we're
here to do
you guys get us there we'll do our
little bit but when it's time to win a
ball game Yo Kids Murray do it for us
Jimmy Butler bam do it for us
Tyler hero is he available for the NBA
Finals do you know any update yet I I
know the cast is off he has not been
shooting at
allstra said uh he's shooting a lot of
left-hand free throws he's still
conditioning because obviously it's just
a hand
um if they get there I wouldn't be
surprised if he could play Spot minutes
but to me I think that would kind of
mess up their chemistry they are so
locked in with this rotation now
um the question tonight will be the
availability of Kevin Love he only
played five minutes he went out with
that ankle or calf injury is he flying
to play tonight can he play his normal
minutes because they're down bodies zero
all the depot and right now they're in a
good nine-man rotation if you take love
out the rotation tonight or for some
reason
um there's not enough surfaceable bodies
for for uh Eric smolstra Caleb Martin
I mean these undrafted players are just
playing out of their minds right now out
of their mind how dangerous is Miami as
a city for an NBA player well I'm sure
it's a lot of want it's won a lot of
games right did you ever suffer from the
Miami South Beach is undefeated
self-control the Miami flu did you ever
have that Reg uh
once I think maybe I have that but I was
injured coming to
I'll tell you when it was it was the
return of Michael Jordan that game I'm
back in his first game back in Indiana
when we beat them by the way and I got
hurt down the stretch of that game but
we had it was a back-to-back for us and
the next game was in Florida and
said it was the injury that occurred in
that Chicago game
but South Beach one
uh we uh we brought this up whose career
would you want to have
um
but Marv do you remember what it was uh
Andre Iguodala
and who was Christian Laettner or
Carmelo Anthony oh Carmelo Anthony or
Andre iguodala's career
wow ah
Finals MVP couple of titles not not an
All-Star maybe a one-time All-Star
mellow's got a lot of points
okay now remember Hall of Fame includes
yeah college so Carmelo championship at
Syracuse yeah
uh top 10 scorer of all time yeah
10 plus all stars I believe three or
four gold medals yeah I'm rolling with
Carmelo Anthony okay four gold medals
okay four gold medals all right I'm
rolling with carmel Carmelo or Christian
Laettner
Carmelo Anthony okay all right a little
bit of a pause there
well uh Leitner one two at Duke right
yeah went to four final fours
uh gold medal the original Dream Team
yeah
so that's huge uh it was good in the
pros not great well just good right he
played a long time
is he uh he's not in the Hall yet no is
he no
I I would think he should be in the hall
don't you think oh yeah he's going in
for his college career no you should go
in don't you think you should go in the
NBA Hall of Fame and well no it's the
college it's it's the name Smith
apparently he's in the college Hall of
Fame but don't you think he needs to be
in the basement that's the only one yeah
that yes of course
there's there might be a College
Basketball Hall of Fame but nobody talks
about that it's the it's the Basketball
Hall of Fame but he's been out of the
game for a while the question is why
hasn't he been up for induction I don't
know I was wondering that that you would
think it's probably one of the five
greatest college basketball players of
all absolutely right absolutely Kareem
uh Walton yeah
um
Alvin Hayes would you put Alvin Hayes as
one of the greatest no
okay
how about Patrick Ewing
yes Patrick Ewing
did you put MJ in there well remember
when ESPN had their experts rank the
college basketball player of all time
last 50 years and they voted Michael
Jordan which I I was disappointed
embarrassed for some people to say that
they thought Mike was worthy was the
best player on that team
so that's true worthy was
yeah on that team did worthy have a
better career than MJ at North Carolina
because they both left after their
junior year right because worthy wants
to the pros after that Championship
versus Georgetown right yeah I I'd say
it's pretty close uh it's close in terms
of their who was the greater Tar Heel
yeah between yes okay so if it's that
close then I think you would have to put
Jordan as
one of the top five to ten greatest
college players no no no no no
no
well who else you putting on there well
I'd have to I'd have to figure that out
okay let me uh let me ask you a question
okay
whose college career would you rather
have
Michael Jordan
or Tyler hansborough Olive career
college career I don't know if
Hansbrough has a title I think he does
so I'm gonna say Tyler hansbrough's
college career
now he was at North Carolina I think
seven years so
but but hands hands bro is the all-time
leading scorer in ACC history yeah yeah
and you got a title so if I just do the
college Mike had the shot to win a title
that's big but Keith smart had a shot to
win a title too for True Indiana Hasbro
does have a title that Carolina I think
so Marvin does hansborough have a title
2009 yes yeah 09 yeah
in college
man you what are you what's in your mug
down there
you're you're still afraid you're still
afraid of Jordan you're still afraid
he's not in your room he's not gonna get
he already doesn't like it Mike doesn't
like you anyway so you know Tyler hands
bro had a better college career than
Michael Jordan so if that's the case
then Christian Laettner had a better
college career than Michael Jordan too
absolutely
okay
I I'm not quite rolling with that
Christian Laettner was a better college
player than Michael Jordan
free your mind the rest will follow okay
come on don't be afraid okay yeah I've
got uh
because that's when you get you know
when we get to hear from the real people
oh yeah oh I know I look I know Mike's
the greatest player of all time but if I
look at if I just said this career
versus this career and I didn't attach
any names
you would go well that guy's the
all-time leading scorer in ACC history
he won a title that guy
great player second best player on his
team for a little while and hit one of
the biggest shots but now remember Mike
Mike left after his
junior year right yeah he stayed two
more years after the shot his freshman
year correct yeah I think so and Hasbro
was there 12 years
okay all right how about how about we
give Tyler Hans Bros followers for a
change reg I'm giving him
who came up with the question I'm giving
him his flowers on the show right yeah
but you just you know what I mean I am
putting him in the same breath as
Michael Jordan you just wanted to know
what I was drinking or smoking
that's a it's very valid very valid
it's medicinal okay it's medicinal uh if
you get a chance to put in Al Horford
future Hall of Famer that'll be okay
better career Al Horford
two tiles at Florida Crisco uh Christian
Laettner Christian Layton Okay Tyler
Hansbrough Al Horford here we go
now that to me
your career Tyler hansbro in college or
you
or he has the championship he's got the
Chip he's got the chip yeah but if you
took away the chip I take my numbers my
four years versus his four years any day
if you take away the chip okay but we
can't
you can't we can't so so Tyler Hans bro
yes Paulie I have Reggie's College
numbers junior year 26 a game senior
year 23 again
yeah and they in his junior year there's
no three-point line is that right reg
that's right he didn't come into my
senior year so imagine if I would have
had a three-point line my junior year I
would average 35. you would get you
would average 27 a game
they wouldn't have let you shoot that
dual Rock bomb better known as well let
me Let It Fly baby
have fun tonight thank you Theodore
Dennis love y'all Reggie Miller be on
the call game four Eastern Conference
Finals Celtics heat that's 8 30 Eastern
on TNT we'll close up shop last call for
phone calls after this